pour la journée mondiale de la liberté
de la presse le président de la
république emmanuel macron a publié ce
tweet volontariste les journalistes nous
informent écrit le locataire de l'élysée
continuons à nous battre pour qu'ils
restent libres partout dans le monde
continuons à nous battre pour les
protéger continuons à nous battre contre
la désinformation qui menacent nos
démocraties pour la paix la justice les
droits humains un message rapidement
contestée par des internautes qui font
remarquer au président français que la
liberté de la presse est menacée
y compris dans son pays notamment depuis
son élection en 2017
et il est vrai que si emmanuel macron
souhaite protéger les journalistes
on pourrait commencer par ceux qui
travaillent en france en pointant à la
34e place du classement de l'omg
reporters sans frontières l'hexagone
reste coincé à une place qu'il occupe
depuis plusieurs années déjà
lo ng exprime notamment ses inquiétudes
concernant les interpellations de
journalistes
des faits qui se sont produits ces
derniers mois souvent dans le cadre de
manifestations une relation entre les
forces de l'ordre et les journalistes
déjà compliquée que l'adoption de la loi
sécurité globale n'a fait que détériorer
le fameux article 24 visant à protéger
les forces de l'ordre contre la
diffusion de leur identité a créé un
flou législatif sur la possibilité de
filmer les policiers et les gendarmes
c'est dans ce contexte qu'un rapport a
été remis au premier ministre
rédigé par une commission indépendante
il formule 32 propositions pour tenter
de corriger cette dégradation des
relations entre les deux professions
s'agissant de la possibilité de les
filmer le rapport propose je cite de
rappeler clairement aux forces de
l'ordre qu'elles ne peuvent en principe
se poser à la captation d'image ou de
sons des opérations qu'il mène dans les
lieux publics ni a fortiori demandait la
suppression de tels enregistrements
reste à voir maintenant ce que matignon
fera de ces propositions toujours est il
que les alertes de la part des ong
telles qu'amnesty international ou
d'institutions comme le conseil de
l'europe se multiplient à l'égard de la
france
ce dernier demandant encore tout
récemment des actions concrètes de la
part des gouvernements européens pour
garantir la sécurité des journalistes le
plus grand nombre d'atteintes à
l'intégrité physique des journalistes a
été signé
les dans la fédération de russie en
italie et au royaume uni la france la
pologne la turquie et l'ukraine compte
pour l'heure par le plus grand nombre de
cas d'intimidation et de harcèlement de
journalistes
et si ces méfaits précède pour beaucoup
le mandat des modèles macron ce dernier
n'est pas beaucoup agi pour garantir la
liberté d'informer l'ancien ministre de
l'économie entretient une relation pour
le moins particulière avec les
journalistes
observateur avisé du paysage médiatique
il a toutefois fait apparaître une forme
de distance quasiment du mépris pour les
journalistes
et puis comment ne pas rappeler que
l'actuel locataire de l'elysée a décidé
de ne pas accepter les journalistes de
notre média au sein du palais
présidentiel
rt france persona non grata lors des
conférences de presse de l'elysée tout
comme lors des meetings de campagne de
la république en marche
si on résume pour emmanuel macron
défendre les journalistes
oui mais seulement ceux qu'il a choisis